the complaints were serious allegations
megan had bullied staff claims that she
has always denied but after the palace
privately hired a law firm to look not
into what was said or done but how it
was handled they now won't tell us what
the findings are
a senior palace source said because of
the confidentiality of the discussions
we have not communicated the detailed
recommendations the recommendations have
been incorporated within policies and
procedures wherever appropriate and
policies and procedures have changed so
all members of staff all members of the
royal family will be aware
experts believe they could have gone
further if they wanted to if the palace
want to
keep things on an even keel between
the family which is what i think they
probably do want to do
and um keep their public relations
positive i think they they should
probably say something along the lines
of some protocols were not followed and
we've intervened to to make sure these
are more robust and training has been
given that kind of thing a little bit
more i suppose taking responsibility
former staff i've spoken to say only a
very limited number of people were
involved in the investigation others
clearly just want to move on but it's
all again come up as the palace let us
look at their annual finances which show
the monarchy cost the taxpayer 102.4
million pounds in the past financial
year
prince charles is two days in barbados
to see it becoming a republic costing a
hundred and thirty eight thousand pounds
and the cambridge's caribbean week-long
tour more than
226 000
they are now using sustainable fuel on
the royal flight where they can to boost
their environmental credentials
is it appropriate to accept
millions of cash for your charity sir
it has been a week where the issue of
transparency has already come up after
reports prince charles was given bags of
cash for his charity by a former qatari
prime minister not illegal and a senior
aide has said it wouldn't happen now
but certainly raising questions about
judgment and the optics of what they
seem to do
which is why a lack of openness
especially around matters involving
family continues to clash with their
preferred image of a forward thinking
institution
rhiannon mills sky news